it was more of a leadership role in
troop advising the sermon major because
i was acting as the ground force
commander for every op
so i lo i started learning a lot about
processes
you know like before i was just in a nug
assaulter i was called a ghost assaulter
just there
doing my little narrow piece of the pie
now i had to step back
and get the big picture i had to control
air assets i had to
flex to different targets i had to
strategize on the fly
with my troops art major deploying his
troops and we had a whole bunch of
incidents like where
you know me and the eod guy the navy eod
guy are hitting targets by herself
because they're hitting a building we
get intel i don't have enough time to
flex that whole troop
we have to do it so we go inside of
houses by ourself
and it was fun man we had a blast it was
like it was cool because we had the
leash off
and even though it wasn't as active i
mean we were doing i remember we had
intel from a soccer field that they had
a couple handsets that correlated to the
soccer field and i was like
all right we got to get the soccer field
so i said hey guys we're going to move
to the soccer field
so we started walking i'm like i need
you guys to move out and they wouldn't
move out
i grabbed the eod guy we sprinted to the
soccer field
as we ran around the block that we were
an ambient street light
the group of guys were meeting and they
were in the middle of soccer field the
middle night like two in the morning
they see us and we're sprinting across
an open field
trying to shoot like 10 dudes who move
in 10 different directions
and we miss everybody and and when we
get back the uh
everybody in the jock and the talk is
laughing because they're like dude
that was the best [ __ ] we've ever seen
because we saw you guys break contact
from the main element and you're like
screw it
and you start sprinting but they all
went 10 different directions so we
couldn't track any of them
and we're running and shooting and we're
standing there in the field like
damn it that was our opportunity it was
good times man
uh wrap up that deployment then what's
next so i
i i get back and i go to kag
and i'm in kag in a a techno-choral
reconnaissance role
and i go back to iraq and to blot and i
only
i i run because of my reconnaissance
background
is how i got recruited in i run a joint
interagency task force
of um interagency organizations with
jsoc
to do reconnaissance over the entire
country of iraq
i was i was undercover as a lieutenant
colonel so i was an oic
young oic nobody believed it
but put it in that position to see to
and control
all the things that were going on for
reconnaissance assets in the country
now in balad at that time period because
everything was uh
downsizing including the base of blood
what year is this now oh nine
yeah so stuff's really slowing down
really slowing down in fact the reason
they brought me in is because
reconnaissance
is obviously another way we get involved
without
involving packs on the ground people on
the ground so
we still have a have eyes on but we had
to use technical means
of reconnaissance and not just depend on
dudes and hide sites
in fact during that time period there
was a restriction of one or two
americans
per target and you had to stay in
containment so if you're moving to a bad
guy place
you leave behind the americans they'd
stay on containment with the vehicles
um indigenous force would hit the
objective come back
and then you'd roll out and so at that
time working the joint interior agency
i didn't feel like i was missing out on
much i felt like i had a broader role to
fill
in that in that capacity and then and
you're just
overseeing all this reconnaissance
elements that's what you're saying all
of it i i
i had daily vtcs with
uh still team command navsoff and
mostly which was the main effort by the
way there wasn't a lot of sf guys in the
country event
at that time so i had daily vtcs with
the navy
and supported their operations and
technical reconnaissance means tagging
tracking locating
all the all the sexy stuff for a
technical recon
um for the entire country and that was
based on the fact that you had
sniper experience yeah i got recruited
econ
experience or whatever yeah i got
recruited i went to selection all
successful and then
um my background my entire life my
background in special operations was
mapped for that that feel of expertise
in the transition coming back from 0809
i went to jay sock's uh
technical reconnaissance course which
was like six months a pretty intense
course
and learned a whole new world
of of operations that i didn't even know
existed i know a little bit but when i
went to that course i was like
whoa now this is this is some cool [ __ ]
so i
i did that for task force for jsoc for
my 009 rotation
and then what happened after that um got
back
and then um got with another squadron
and at that time we hadn't been in iraq
since we killed zarqawi the task force
hasn't been in iraq
really since i mean intermittently um
we we owned iraq but afghanistan we
completely gave up so our eye wasn't
uh on the ball in afghanistan because we
were too busy in iraq
and then all of a sudden we had a change
of heart um
like al qaeda was on the run we didn't
even know this thing called isis
existed and we decided to do a surge
as an organization to afghanistan and i
was on the first thing smoking
so my first real
good deployment with that organization
with the special missions unit
was in afghanistan and when we got there
um the rangers on the battle space
colonel carrillo
was in charge and we were the red-headed
step-children
and i was like what how's in smu the
step children like when i got there
i was taking showers with bottles of
water in an open field and i'm like
this is the premier ct unit on the
planet and i'm doing this and like dude
we have to we're building everything
from scratch so we set up shop there
and started targeting bad guys and it
the first two months was prep and then
the second two months was killing bad
guys
um and we did a lot of it that that that
second 60 days of that four-month
rotation
we i saw more bad guys killed in a
two-month period than
anything that i experienced before and
it was because of the assets that we
brought to bear
um good rotation though and you were you
were still overseeing recce at this
point yeah
i was i was that squadron's
reconnaissance
nco which just specialized in recon
so everything from ops to technical
recce
to uh um interagency like even
controlling aircraft
for for isr and it was an active trip i
mean we lost a dog
we had guys shot we had guys blown up um
a lot of active operations during that
period of time it was it was amazing to
see
the talent and
you can't really get an idea or
understanding of that talent
and capability when you when you focus
on individuals
but when you see it come together in a
single combat operation
where everybody's so efficient and
effective you really see the benefit
of the selection process the training
process
and the support mechanisms that make
that unit
the the most elite unit in the world
yeah you know you hear like the um
sports analogies
of like well you know it's like a
professional sports team but
these are like the champions right these
are the nfl
freaking super bowl winners that you
know that you see the super bowl guy
that like um
whatever gets his right arm massaged so
that he can
whatever and he and this other guy is
doing speed drills with
the first four meters of his sprint and
he's going to work with a specialist
that's going to get him even a little
bit you know
one millisecond faster and then they're
getting their helmets dialed in so that
they can have calms in there
and they got this you know they get all
like this 100
pure focus for every individual to be as
good as they possibly can and then you
put that team together
and every one of those individuals is
100 focused on being as good as they
possibly can
with all the support they could possibly
want and that's what you end up with
just just freaking the best yeah it's
the big leagues for sure and i
what i realized in that unit even being
a very competent shooter
a respected member of um special forces
and um being a pt stud at the time
that there was men above me and beyond
me that i'd never catch up with
that were just so talented and i was
like it was humbling and i'm like
well i'm not the most elite dude i
thought i was i woke up and went
dude i'm crushing it and then i see the
talent pool over there and realized
um there's this thing this machine and
like you said before
um these guys aren't trained to be
diplomats
to be fit experts they're trying to kill
bad guys
and they're the best at it i mean the
navy version and the army version
they're the best
at it in the world and it was a humbling
and honorable experience of being part
of that